you have a vision have a vision have a
vision have a vision
had a vision have extraordinary
imaginative
vision we have a very clear vision have
a very clear vision
had a vision
we are old and sure we're tired it's
been a long season
but mentally we we have a we have a
vision we have a finish
that we have to attain you know and
sometimes you have to do it when you old
and you're tired
you know and i think it's the test
of your will to succeed when you have to
deal with
you know some of these negatives and i'm
pretty sure
you know by the end of this playoffs
you'll see the old and the tired people
were very very young and strong mentally
you know most people
and here's the irony is that most people
don't have
a compelling vision for their own future
they don't they move through life
setting goals
and goals have no power we're almost
we're at this point you know goals had
power in 1959 when
earl nightingale came with this idea of
goal setting and everyone's like wow i'm
a goal-oriented person and that was
great it worked like 20 years everyone
set goals and they and they got results
but then all of a sudden you know you
set goals
and sometimes you hit them sometimes you
don't mo most times you don't okay
that's okay
but goals almost became like a synonym
for like oh i'm gonna set a goal who
gives us what really happens afterwards
and it almost is synonymous with failure
now goal setting there's something above
and i believe in setting goals but
there's got to be something above your
goals and that's your vision
for the future and it's not just about
it doesn't have like an ending point
it's about the world
being a certain way and that's inspiring
to you when you when you truly have a
vision for your future that inspires you
you're going to jump up out of bed in
the morning and feel great about going
at life versus being miserable and
going to a job you hate or living a life
that doesn't empower you and just
you know every day moving through just
almost like an automaton not really
you know having the zest and the great
the greatness of life
and i'm guilty i've been there myself
when i felt
like i didn't really have a compelling
vision for my own future and i felt like
i was wallowing
but at least i'm conscious of that once
you become conscious of that
you can consciously create a vision for
your future it doesn't happen in once
in one minute or an hour you write it
down you work on it until
when you finally hit on it you know how
you know you got it when when you read
it back to yourself your vision
statement
and it moves you and you feel inspired
okay and you know so few people have
that
and and what happens is every human
being is thirsty for a vision
everyone is and so few people haven't so
what i do they gravitate
towards someone who has a vision for the
future because they want to be a part of
her vision
part of being a great entrepreneur is
having
that vision being able to create the
vision and then sell that vision
to other people to get them to want to
be inspired to buy into it
to put in their time their hard work
their elbow grease to help
you achieve your vision if you're a
smartest one then you spread the wealth
around it
it's a win-win for everybody you got to
have a vision
a vision for what it is you really truly
want
not what you think you want or what you
should have i mean what are most
people's new year's resolutions i'm
going to stop eating sugar
you know i'm going to stop smoking i'm
going to lose 10 pounds
the problem with that is it's not very
inspiring for most people
you know it's not telling you what
you're going to get it's only what
you're not going to do and it's kind of
hard to have you move forward with that
a vision is about what you're here to
create a vision
that really works is one that excites
you if you
say well my you know my resolution my
goal my outcome for this month this week
this year is to
lose x number of pounds that's okay but
it's not very compelling
it has to be a compelling vision it's
got to have something has the power to
pull you
not something you have to push yourself
to do those are two different kinds of
motivation
push requires willpower and willpower
never lasts
what will last is pull having something
so exciting so attractive so
something you desire so much that you
have a hard time going to sleep at night
you get so up early in the morning to a
rocket and take it to the next level
that's what you're looking to create
that isn't easy to get but one of the
reasons we do seminars and events and we
say you know why do that why isn't why
not just read a book or something is
because when you get an environment
where you're with people that are being
put in a peak state like when you're
going to
a sporting event if you watch the
sporting event at home it might have a
certain level of excitement but
when you're in a stadium with 50 000
people suddenly it has a whole different
level of intensity
when we feel that and the bottom line of
our follow-through comes down to our
emotional intensity
in a different state of mind you're
going to come up with a much better and
more exciting vision than if you're
sitting the couch going okay what are my
new resolutions for this year and you're
doing it the morning after the year
started and you're a little inebriated
and the football game's on in the
background probably not going to have
the power of focus there probably not
going to power the energy to create
something that's going to pull you for
this year
and you got to do that so it's got to be
a vision that's compelling
something that you know it's going to be
a gift to make sure that it happens
[Music]
[Music]
and uh is what i plan to do in boxing
it's good for livelihood but mainly
uh money don't really mean nothing
because i proved that when i gave up the
title not knowing if i'm coming back or
not for four years
and they let me back on my terms i
didn't deny nothing i believe it's still
the same everything so if even today if
my title
hadn't been given back to them if i got
such a poverty where i had to go find a
job i would have did that
but i was i made a good living speaking
in colleges because the war got
unpopular
and so many black militants who were
trying to do all they could and i was
naturally right in the middle of all of
it and represented it and that kept me
alive
but if i couldn't fight i would still
not be fighting so number one
comes freedom first of my people
equality and this is
what i plan to do after i'm through
fighting working with nothing but the
people the little people and allies the
wine here
the downtrodden people going out among
them and helping them
with my image but you better have a
vision
for what you want you better have very
clear in your mind what you want for
your life
what you want for your family
what you want for your business
so many of us never
take the time we don't see the value
in truly shaping and molding
pictures in our mind of what we want our
life to look like
we think that's a waste of time we think
that's woo
we think that's like the movie the
secret listen
seriously there is something to vision
because
you are going to face moments in your
life when the doors will be closed
if a door is closed does that mean you
are not allowed to have what's on the
other side
i don't believe so
sometimes you're gonna have people and
events feel like that they're chasing
after you barreling down on you
does that mean what you want's not for
you
i don't believe so i believe
you showed up here because whether it's
clear or not for you yet
you have somewhat of a vision for what
you'd like to have
and this is just a means to an end
you're here to learn about how to grow
your business
how to put more money into your pockets
and into your families and into your
dreams
but more important than your business is
i want you to set up a clear
vision for what you want for you for
your life
because if a person does not have their
vision
clear and they constantly get blown
around
by the winds of life they're constantly
they're grabbing for straws they're just
chasing something get
very clear what does your life look like
one year from now
five years from now 20 years from now
the great companies
had a vision that had a higher purpose
beyond just money or profits or
being number one in a market and kind of
the irony
there is that by not making profits the
number one priority of the company or
the higher purpose of the company
it actually enabled these companies to
make generate more profits
in the long term so sometimes when i
speak at entrepreneur conferences i get
asked
what's a good market to go into where
they can make a lot of money
and my response to them is instead of
thinking about where you can make a lot
of money
think about what are you so passionate
about doing that you'd be happy doing it
for 10 years
and even if you never made a dime and
that's what you should be doing
and kind of the ironic thing is the
money will actually follow so
you know we've all heard of craigslist
he didn't
set out to make money he was passionate
about the community and now it's one of
the top
traffic websites on the internet so i
like to say chase the vision
not the money there was a movie that
came out a uh
i think a couple years ago called
notorious i think it only lasted a week
in the movie theater but
but i saw it and in it
biggie smalls also known as notorious
b.i.g
is well puffed out he says to biggie
smalls don't chase the paper
chase the dream i just want an excuse to
put this picture up here
anyways so if you're an entrepreneur say
think about what would you be so
passionate about doing
that you'd be happy doing it for 10
years even if you never made a dime from
it
and if you have employees think about
what's the larger vision
and greater purpose in their work beyond
just money or profits or
being number one in a market people are
successful have
extraordinary imaginative vision
and elon musk calls it a more
complicated term
which is arguing from first cause is not
analogy so here's what arguing from
analogy
or not having extraordinary imaging
division let's say you're in a horrible
place
you're you were sleeping in your car
yeah i was sleeping on a couch
someone born in ghetto someone born in
poor party india if you argue from
um uh i'm sorry arguing from analogy
means
well everybody around me is doing bad
i'm doing bad
therefore i'm gonna always do bad
that's arguing from analogy and that's
not having
imaginative vision the people who make
it
are the people who do the opposite they
go i'm going to argue from first
causes i'm going to say has anybody ever
written a written
risen up from the ashes out of the
ghetto or from the couch or from the car
the answer is we all know that story so
if somebody else did it
then if you use extraordinary creative
imagination then why can't you do it too
and that's arguing from first causes
that's what allowed elon musk to make
tesla
spaceships solar city so for all of us
we get stuck
when we argue from analogy well you know
last time i started a business it failed
last time i trusted somebody they
betrayed me well that's good that's
arguing from analogy that's just saying
because it happened before it's gonna
happen
it doesn't always work that way
sometimes
you do it better you double down on your
brain you learn from the mistakes of
others and your mistakes
and the next thing you create something
new
and that's where wealth comes from not
just wealth in your bank account
wealth of happiness love health
everything you want
to me we have a very clear vision of
what it is that we're trying to get done
and i want to stay true to that
we are absolutely the biggest bet we
have is our organic bed always
always anyway it's true even for michael
uh and then on top of that
we'll look at any opportunity that fits
with where we want to get to what is it
that we can uniquely do
if anything that i ask myself each day
is
i don't want to be in every part of the
tech industry i want to be in
things that are big addressable markets
where microsoft has a unique
contribution to make
because i think that sense of purpose
and identity
is what makes companies successful not
just doing everything
uh and so to me that's what will drive
whatever we do organically and
whatever we do inorganically you've got
to be able to have a very clear vision
of your business idea without it
you won't actually know where you're
going so in the year 2000 i set up
generation telecom
and generation telecom was a business
that supplied air time
to the rail users i believe that i could
set up
and manage this business and within two
or three years
sell out to the major networks well
within three years we successfully sold
it
to vodafone making millions of pounds
but without that vision
at the outset my business would not have
gone the way that it did
when you look at it you know it is
really not common
for somebody to leave banking and go and
start something
totally new you know especially in an
area of
events management because at the time
that she left the bank
which was 10 years ago nobody thought
that
something like events management will
actually succeed but i mean it is good
that is
really what you call entrepreneurship
and also a vision you know she had a
vision and she
is able to actualize our vision it's
just like myself
i remember one time i went to
address a retreat of first bank of
nigeria and i was selling first worker
for nigeria
this is where the is going to be in the
next five years i mean they were not
really that big at the time that i went
there to
address them and i'm sure you know they
couldn't really believe what i was
saying
then but i remember at a point
the md said that well you know they are
really shocked at
how we actually been able to make it and
also
actualize our vision so i think with
this thing that she has
done i personally believe it is just
beginning of the
journey because she has a vision and i'm
sure if she continues to do this can
turn
into another mega business you know
because
like what i always say look
for an entrepreneur there are no
boundaries not only are there no
boundaries
you can actually excel much more than
your own expectation
and that's really what i expect of an
entrepreneur to be
not to just say okay fine i have a
vision and only achieve that your vision
you
need to have a vision and a mission so
that you can actually
actualize it and also excel i mean i had
somebody
who came to interview me one time and i
told him that yes you know three
four five years ago i never ever
expected myself
to be on the forbes list
but right now the vision that i have
and also my own mission is actually to
be on top of the light
not even where i am today and that's
really how
you know a visionary person should be
thank you guys so much for watching i'd
love to know
what your vision is for your business as
well as which of the clips that you saw
here
is gonna have the biggest impact on you
leave it in the comments below i'm gonna
join the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe
and i'll see you soon